this is a place UNLV hasn't been in  years three in one start the city is  bumping it's a Friday night and they're  the only game in town what else could  you ask for well for being picky we  could ask for a better start the Lobos  go out and grab the first 17 points in  the game that is the largest deficit the  rape the rebels have faced all season  long but unlike a 2AM you up text they  responded Doug Brumfield trailing by  eight points rolling out and going to  put the body on the line just like he  did two weeks ago against North Texas  rushing touchdown while getting smacked  that is a dedicated fella two-pointer  was good and we're all tied up at 17.  first minute of the fourth quarter we go  Aiden Robbins moves into second in the  nation for rushing touchdowns with this  one his eighth of the Year UNLV has the  lead and that is where it stood for a  long time but they have just gone final  the rebels their third four and one  start in the last 41 seasons